a lot of the skill set that i gained
from being a software engineer could
also benefit in
other roles and other industries
[Music]
all right morgan thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you for having me michael i'm very
happy to be here
really great to have you so you're
calling from israel from tel aviv
yeah true it's uh here you know yeah
happy holidays
yeah so going to eat a lot tonight
wonderful wonderful yeah i'm very
jealous my family's having a wonderful
dinner right now
and hopefully next year this time i can
be with them but you know with with
covet we're learning that everything is
virtual so
trying to also embrace that yeah i'm
sure you did the passover also
via zoom together with all the family
unbelievable unbelievable really unique
so more and
you know it's such a unique privilege to
speak with you know i i went through 8
200 for
for five years you're running eisp which
you'll tell me what it's about in a
second but it's very very relevant to
but you also have a very technical
background yourself as a software
engineer from vmware
and i'm fascinated to hear about your
intersection between
running an incredible community and
accelerators such as eisp
while also you know being technical
yourself
and how does this all relate to also
women in tech which is also something
you're very passionate about
let's just get started what is eisp
yeah perfect uh so we're studying from
the end actually
uh but we'll get to the beginning uh
probably
uh so the asp is a startup accelerator
in israel it was founded by the 8200
alumni association
10 years ago when actually the ecosystem
in israel
uh it was already a good ecosystem but
there were not so many
uh formal uh programs for entrepreneurs
in their early stages
so it was one of the first uh and it is
one of the leading one in israel today
so we early stage entrepreneurs helping
them
build and grow their ventures and we
have some great companies in our
portfolio
so what why what is 8200 apartment
because my understanding is
it's not exclusively for the 8200 and
for
anybody who doesn't know the 200 it's
the cyber security uh considered like
the elite unit of the army for
the computer nerds uh like we are true
so i think uh like that when the alumni
association started to think about
activities and what they can do in the
israeli
uh society and help israel israel
society
so you said it's a very elite tech unit
but then when you look at the industry a
lot of the startups that were founded in
and the good ones in israel were founded
by 8200 alumni
uh so it was very natural uh to think
about the entrepreneurship and the
innovation uh ecosystems
and see how we can contribute there and
then
at first uh they thought about okay so
within the 8200
uh unit you get great skill set
you get great experience and you get a
great network which helps you along the
way throughout your career and also
once we get to it you will see how it
also helped mine
uh but um but other people who are not
necessarily serves and
serve are serving in these units they do
not benefit from the same
uh being part of this community so the
logic was let's do
uh the other way around so usually
alumni association they work for their
own alumni
and the 800 alumni association decided
to work for
israel uh community and society as a
whole
and taking that this closed network
of 8200 alumni and open it to any
uh israeli entrepreneur and this is a
kind of uh the dna of the the program
and the alumni association itself very
okay so now how are you related to that
and you mentioned that it
also very much impacted your own your
own upbringing into the tech world
true so i think that ever since i was
very very young i was always very
passionate about tech
i know i was always thought that i would
like to pursue a career in tech
so obviously and i know that you're also
an 8200 alumni uh so you know so
when i was like 16 i started my uh the
process uh to getting drafted to the
israeli defense
israel defense forces and after passing
so many interviews and exams i was
accepted to the 8200 unit
i did an intelligence course there uh
which really opened uh my
mind uh to the wonderful things you can
do with technology
uh after the army i studied also
computer science and statistics so i
wanted to get more the theoretical
um understanding of how things how to
think
correctly about solving problems in
general but
also specifically like
tech problems and then i was working for
a while as a software engineer
uh i think that along the way i
understood that
a lot of the skill set that i gained
from being a software engineer could
also benefit in
other roles and other uh industries
uh and then uh i wanted to tap into the
more
a little bit about that though more i
have to stop you
the the this idea because i agree
completely this idea that
the skill sets you're you're getting as
a software engineer that are
are you know indirectly very relevant to
a lot of other industries
what's your take on that so i absolutely
agree and
along the way and throughout my career i
think
time and time again i see that this is
true
uh so basically everyone think that
being a software engineer is like
programming but it's more than that it
starts with uh
getting a vague problem you know have to
do something that you don't necessarily
know how to approach to or what to do
and then doing it very efficiently uh
and doing it you know
so you have a vague problem you have to
break it into little components you know
think about each of them
do a lot of iterations make it better
make it more efficient
and then um i think once you have that
logical and very structured
way of thinking about problems in
general and
approaching challenges uh if you know
how to
also implement that in other industries
and in other
roles so this really helped so after
working as a software engineer
i went to strategy consulting which is
almost
180 uh and there i really saw it because
you coming
you you're you're coming for a very
short while you're joining a company for
for like three months and you have like
uh
an enormous scope of work your work is
like you have to
basically come up with a new strategy to
a company who is working for
30 years everything is great they are
growing but now something is
missing or they're uh they want to be
better
and then you have to understand
how to break it and understand where are
the
what are the main issues uh what
hypothesis you can make
uh challenge all kinds of assumptions
that they have
and this way of thinking really helped
me also
as a strategy consultant
[Applause]
i mean this whole idea this magnificent
idea that you're taking a huge huge
problem anything in life it can be
you know an algorithm but it can be you
know a a
a leadership position or a strategy and
this methodology of breaking it down of
divide and conquer
and then piecing them together back to
understand that you know everything is
manageable
it's only a mindset of how how efficient
they are able to
to to divide it and then conquer it i
think that's just phenomenal so you went
to strategy you did
you did those you know that those
consulting which i think
that's definitely something that i look
forward to experiencing one day as well
because you're coming in and you're
getting these
these really interesting insights and
then you go into
the accelerator phase or the community
phase right
so yeah so this is almost the story
uh this is very uh so i
i always knew that in some point i would
like to take the the experience that i
have that i've gained
uh as a business and strategy consultant
uh and go back into the tech world
because this is uh this was my starting
position this is
really who i am basically uh and then
i knew i didn't know how it will connect
uh but i knew it will connect at some
point
i actually add uh
all a plans to go and pursue an mba
uh but then yeah uh but then i met
sharin which you know very well uh she
was the previous uh
managing director my uh my ancestor
let's say
um and uh she
we met and then she offered like a few
months after
uh we met he offered me this role uh
which
totally changed everything for me
because uh i was really on uh
on like i already had my application
written
the gmat did everything uh and it was
like
around august which is very uh close to
the deadlines
um and then it took me like a
few i think like 48 hours uh to think
about that and uh
and i felt that this is exactly the
opportunity
the opportunity that i've been waiting
for in that time in my career
uh to take my uh a
tech experience together with my uh
consultant experience combining them to
assist
early stage entrepreneurs and i'm very
happy that uh
that i did that so so more how many
entrepreneurs did you get to work with
personally throughout your time at eisp
so the ones that were part of like the
cohort that i led
uh around let's say 30 uh but
then obviously we support our alumni
community
which is like 120 startups
yeah in different stages different
verticals which is a whole different
challenge
and then uh on my spare time
if i have that i like helping other
entrepreneurs who did not
who were not accepted to our program i
think it's very important to give them
the proper feedback and try to help if
you you have
the network and the experience uh try to
help wherever you can
amazing no i actually have two great
friends who did the program recently
tomorrow
arts and
[Applause]
he actually sat next to me in the army
for about a year and a half
we were on the same team incredible
incredible people
uh and and they just mentioned how
incredible the program is
so what what are what are some of the
values that you bring into the program
when you look at an accelerator and you
look at you know the 150
entrepreneurs that have gone through
this program what makes it unique
versus you know any other accelerator
that just aims to
kick start the progress of these early
stage startups
yeah so i think um
first of all is the the reputation that
we have
and uh you know we're we've been
operating for
10 years uh there are i think very
little
uh like other startups uh not a lot of
startups in the israeli ecosystem that
have been
operating for that long and this means
that we have a lot of experience so
from cycle to cycle year to year
managing director to other
uh we really uh we evolve we learn uh
we we're getting better so i think today
more than that more i think you actually
have the opportunity unlike other
accelerators you see the whole life
cycle from inception to potentially exit
because the average life cycle of a
startup is seven to nine years
so you actually get to now debrief over
your
initial courts and see okay what
happened over these seven to nine years
true so we have the data and we're
following the data and we're seeing
like uh we're trying to learn from that
you know which companies we can help and
which one if we did the right that we
selected them properly and we have some
companies already
as you said they already exited uh and i
think so
first is the experience the reputation
second uh it's the network
uh so we're not only approaching 8200
uh alumni but the background uh
is 8 200 alumni so and within that
network
in israel and also in silicon valley san
francisco and all around the world there
is there there is a strong community
which is very united
i'm sure you're taking part in the in
the activity of the community
yeah so we uh we really they really
they're really up for the challenge to
assist
entrepreneurs and whenever i approach
someone from the network they're
always always happy to assist opening
doors
giving consultation mentoring the
startups
which is a really great network to have
for entrepreneurs
uh we're a non-profit organization which
is uh different
from other startups it's very different
from other accelerators right it's very
uncommon
true every year we think about that
whether we want to raise a fund and
start investing
or we want to be we want to stay a
non-profit
so we do not take equity we do not
invest which is
nice but i think that more than that it
means that we are
we don't have a specific agenda we
really want to do what's best for the
company
uh i think that if you're backed by a
specific vc or backed by a corporate
so obviously you want to promote their
agenda or
their uh specific uh requirements
and here really if an entrepreneur wants
to raise money he doesn't have any
obligation i will introduce him to all
the vcs that he
that are relevant to him and all the
investors and if he
is not committed to any specific um
uh vcu which i think is really great um
and if in israel as you know you know
now with the situation
everything shifts a bit but uh
money is not an issue if you're a good
entrepreneur
it's just come to the investors at the
right timing
and sometimes if you take if you go to
an accelerator it means that you still
need to be
part you need to be to do some polishing
uh but you have amazing raw material and
then if you go to investors then you
would probably won't get the best deal
so i think that uh getting money from
accelerators is not
necessarily uh the best thing for the
company
yeah well micro so i'm going to
challenge you on that because i'm
wondering
do you think that there are some
startups that might
be that might be hesitant to join a to
or to apply to 8200
to this accelerator because of the fact
that they're that you're not taking
equity because they might feel that if
you don't have a stake in their company
then maybe you're not going to give them
as much attention as other accelerators
or that you're not going to be as
advocative in helping connect them or
or is that not even a worry for startups
because because
this accelerator is one of the best
well-known accelerators in the country
yeah so that's a good question actually
we always
ask uh the other way around we always
think that
uh so you're asking if because we're not
uh putting money or taking any uh equity
so we will not invest uh we'll not do
our best to help them
maybe i don't know yeah i'm not sure if
that's a concern i never heard
an entrepreneur who is worried about the
program because of that
and this leads me to the you know the
already good
uh results that we have uh you know
talking to even if you talk to thomas
i'm sure he will be able to tell you
and he was one of our he is
i'm sure he would have succeeded without
our help but
you know being able to introduce him to
so many investors and
also uh potential customers was really
uh i'm sure it really helped them but i
don't think
i think if they do uh have any
like if entrepreneurs have this concern
they talk to me i'm very
very approachable i love talking to
entrepreneurs or other alumni in our
uh uh portfolio and then i'm sure that
they won't be worried about that at the
end it's all about what's actually
happening on the field and
i'm seeing all these incredible things
that you're doing for the startups you
know i'm observing on social media and
i'm talking to tomorrow and emory and
all my friends who are doing it
and it's it is one of the best run
accelerators that i've seen
there are so many accelerators that
people come out and they tell me michael
you know
we did this we actually did two
accelerators we feel like uh it was
worth it not so worth it
i only heard rave reviews about about
what you're doing there we just have a
few minutes left which is a shame but i
i'd love to get a little bit about your
passion for women in tech
and then i'm gonna and and then i'll
shift it to a few more things that i
have in mind
ah so let's go i'll try to do it uh
quick um
20 minutes goes by really fast when you
enjoy it
it's unbelievable uh so women in tech
so one of my personal passion is about
that so i'm a woman i'm coming from tech
i know
how most of my time i was uh one of a
few
uh during university uh then you know
looking at the industry there are only
around three percent in israel three
percent female entrepreneurs
uh this is something that i care deeply
about uh so
and i think starting with education uh
where i believe
if you need to start there so teaching
young girls
opening their minds to this
at what age do you think is important to
really get in there
from like
age zero yeah all the way from the
beginning is
like exposing them to things that are
more
mechanical scientific and then
also obviously encourage them to explore
uh these ideas
as parents and as you know educator i'm
actually asking that because i read it
recently a very interesting study that
showed that actually
you know up until a certain age girls
outperform a boys in stem
but i think at around fifth or sixth
grade there's these
social norms that are starting to divide
the groups and a lot of scientists are
saying that if we can dive
into that key moment and like in middle
school
when they have these like clicks maybe
that will help a change situation but i
i'll send it to you later i thought it
was very interesting i would love to
read that
so it's very complex obviously because
also as i said there is the social
environment you know
at the age of uh i don't know 10 or 11
if you're not with other girls
you might feel a bit different or
strange uh but then obviously i think
you should start from the beginning my
father
is very feminist he was he was always
like that
which really helped me i think from a
very young age to
understand that there is uh i can do
anything basically i just need to
understand what i want to do and where
is my passion
uh but i think that starting with the
parents uh
this is the point where uh you should
start encouraging girls
explore these areas i love it more last
question
actually i lied i have two more
questions but for now
where do you where do you see yourself
in like 10 15 years curiosity i mean
are you doing a startup are you going
working for a big company
where's your passion wow wisha was brave
enough to start a startup
it's so crazy i really admire
entrepreneurs
um itch after you're seeing all these
people go through
it so i do but i think i like being
an an entrepreneur and being uh
initially
like taking initiatives within a more
structured environment
um so this is where like
at the moment this is uh where uh i
feel more um
like this is where i feel comfortable uh
so
definitely continue to work with
entrepreneurs uh
i'm not sure how uh exactly but
definitely i'm i'm
i'm super i love working with
entrepreneurs um
like seeing them how they're passionate
about what they're doing trying to
change the world and
how i can assist doing that uh
definitely
fulfills um a lot of the things that i'm
looking for in a career
i love it more now the last question
finally
i need three words that best to describe
you or
that any of your startups would describe
you as
i'm sure these would be different three
words
but uh so i think i'm very
i'm ambitious uh i have
um very high emotional intelligence
and i think that i'm very israeli you
know
in every sense of the world yeah yeah
really
this is i've done it with quite a few
israelis this is the first time i'm
hearing that is the word
i just love it thank you so much
i really enjoyed getting to know you
really enjoyed thank you